I mean he's views on defense policies
hark back to the more extreme elements
of the Labour Party of the 60s and 70s
and 80s
his views on nationalization were born
in another century under Karl Marx work
tried extensively in this country and a
lamentable failure and his whole
approach to society I think is to sort
of create an image of society which in
practical terms doesn't work you know
still there has been something of a sea
change some of those ideas you know that
the underpin that kind of a neoliberal
revolution of the past few years the
free markets at the idea of deregulation
privatization people are coming around
to a different way of thinking on every
one of those well you say people there
are some people I spend a lot of my time
with the Labour councillors Labour
leaders in the real world and they are
in dismay about the prospect of a Corbin
led Labour Party so of course you're
quite right to point out to an element
of the Corbin phenomenon it has achieved
they sought a certain sort of vision for
a certain sort of generation but I think
you have to ask why what is the
background that has created this hunger
to change and when you analyze that I
find it common across the Western world
in the post 2008 crash it's produced an
extremism on the right looking for very
simple and really rather than attractive
solutions to try and persuade people
that there is something that's going to
change the frustrations of their life
the frozen living standards the job
losses that have characterized a lot of
the last decade and the nationalism the
the suspicion of foreigner the
immigration issues they all bubble up in
circumstances of this sort but of course
you do get an alternative the other end
the
visionary nationalize everything type of
purge but the real issues that are
undermining the stability of governments
recently I think a much more to do with
those basic political issues of
uncertainty and fear and the immigration
issue which is all part of it
the the job insecurity these are the
issues and the frozen living standards
particularly since 2008 still I remember
too easily making her first speech on
the doorstep of number 10 before even
crossing the threshold properly saying
that no was the time to look again at
the kind of the free market know was the
time to look at the corporate excesses
that have brought so much pain to so
many people and then she did pretty much
nothing about it indeed you know we have
her at the Bank of England not making
that making the case from capitalism not
making the case for reform of capitalism
well personally I've always taken great
pride in the fact that some of the great
reforms of the free market have been led
by conservative administrations I mean
it was the Conservatives who took the
women out of the minds and the children
out of the chimneys in the 19th century
it was Disraeli who gave the working men
the vote it was Neville Chamberlain
associated with great public sector
reforms and if you look at modern
society it is driven in the main by a
partnership between the public sector
and the capitalist system but in a
regulated climate
I mean regulations the interference of
government to insist on standards is
actually the hallmark of civilization
that makes we do not live in a jungle
economy but indeed but at the same time
I mean look at look at young people who
frankly are deserting the kid
conservative cause it in droves and many
of them were who would not have
countenance voting for the Conservatives
you know a few years ago can never see
themselves 14 for them the reason being
well they find it difficult to get a job
when they do have a job it's not paying
them what they feel that they should be
earning it even when they do get a job
that pays and the decent amount of money
they're finding it's so incredibly
difficult to get onto the housing ladder
we hear trees make talking about know
the social contract that every
generation should experience better
condition
I mean in terms of the conservative
hustle performance since 2010 and the
social contracts been broken hasn't it
well you see I think that there were
different causes affecting the young
it's a lack of vision and it's very
difficult to see how in the context of
brexit you produce a vision and what
every government has got to do is to
have an effective program it has to have
a vision as to the journey purpose where
it's going to be and then it has to have
unity now in the conference which is
about to take place what we're going to
see in practice is a sort of fully
dressed but totally revealing political
beauty context in which the contenders
will be all out there strutting their
stuff and that is the worst sort of
background for government that ought to
be concentrating first of all on this
programme for government and secondly on
the vision as to where it should go and
how the vision is bound to include
harnessing the forces of enterprise much
better word of a massive than capitalist
so forces of enterprise in order to
serve the wider causes of public no I
didn't of course want to discuss the
conservative leadership political
programs on Sunday but you never delve
into this topic you dragged me onto
Boris Johnson you know there is a man
with a vision we've heard plenty about
it twice now for exit what on earth is
he up to
well we all know what he's up to he's
making sure that his present position is
the most favourite to succeed to resume
is maintained it is a campaign it's it's
always happens it's what politics
competition is all about and bias is
that there's a master of it there
whether even win or not there's another
matter all-together but we all know what
he's doing master of it well that's the
point I mean he's had huge amounts of
criticism from even some you know
right-leaning newspapers on these two
separate occasions on which he's decided
to intervene okay in your mind when
given the problems that we've been
but we're the Conservative Party is
right now where the party is as regards
young people I mean it's Boris Johnson
the man to sort I personally his views
on brexit are quite unacceptable I
understand who he's appealing to he's
appealing to an elderly part of the
constituent of the society many of them
members of the Conservative Party and he
is appealing to those elements of their
personal conviction that he thinks a
most likely to trigger support for it
and I understand those arguments but
they're phony they're duplicitous they
bear no relationship look at Bombardier
what's going on there that's the real
world of international trade does
anybody who spent any time in the export
market fully understands and so talking
about a sort of world hungry for new
British exporters to suddenly come over
the horizon is just talking about
something it doesn't exist
I mean you yourself have a degree of
form when it comes to intransigence and
insurrection within the Conservative
Party actually no squint your eyes
former MP for Henley you know
occasionally on really mop of here
ability to annoy female conservative
prime ministers I mean do you think
Boris Johnson is in any way emulating
what you got up to well I think that you
have to be draw the character I was the
person that Margaret Thatcher relied on
time and time again to carry through
conservative policies the right to by
self-evidently the battle against CND
the reduction in the size of the public
sector in the various departmental
activities the work I did on the inner
cities all of this with the support of
Margaret Thatcher was only on a specific
issue that we clashed and you resigned
as also easily sack Boris Johnson well I
resigned I think it's very difficult to
abolish to go on making the sort of
interventions that he is and remain in
the government so she to easily replace
him well I I think that the case for
sacking boys is very strong except in
one crucial way that
the danger of doing it in the
fragmentation of Parliament today is
perhaps at bigger risk and so leaving
him there until he completely
overstepped the mark is a wise thing to
do whether it is right in most
circumstances it would be wrong in these
circumstances it might be the only
option it strikes me that there are two
two separate issues here one whether or
not Boris Johnson you know has the
ability to take over the leadership of
the Conservative Party the second
question follows on from that if he has
is he the right man to be Jeremy Corbyn
in the next general election whenever
that might be well maíam gets the
election will be in a couple of years
time and I think that the Conservatives
are going to be lumbered with the
failures of brexit I see no way in which
the Conservatives can actually transform
the performance of the economy in the
two years from now the next election
so he/she ain't who should be the next
leader of well am I in that time scheme
my view is quite clear at the moment I
haven't seen somebody who's prepared to
recognize that the song has to be
changed not just a singer interesting
enough Ruth Davidson in the first break
I've seen from the counter Beck's each
side of the argument today has begun to
qualify the sort of position but but
this whole thing is in but it is
unsustainable you cannot have a
government in which various members of
the cabinet are voicing opinions which
are not consistent one with the other
you say it's unsustainable but at what
point does Theresa May either feel that
she no longer has the authority to carry
on or that the election process is set
in motion I don't think it'll be her
decision it with the point if you ask
the right question that is the point at
which the parliamentary party said we've
had enough in terms of brexit do you
think that the party will will
ultimately see this process through well
I hope not and I have there were grounds
for believing it's possible not likely
at the moment it looks as though Beck's
it is likely to happen but from my money
the events will intervene
the opinion will change and the party
will realize that as labor will actually
become increasingly anti brexit the
Tories are going to be left lumbered
with the responsibility for this thing
but you ever find it quite lonely being
in this position I mean as things stand
I mean it's so there's not a single MP
in any party at the moment who appears
to agree with you it's yourself it's
tony blair to an extent is it's Vince
Cable do you feel like you're on the
right side of the argument given the
weight of opinion against you you know
in the House of Commons well I know what
a lot of those members think they may
not say it and I understand why they
don't say it because politics is about
tribes and they were great penalties to
pay for appearing to differ from your
tribe but I'm not interested in any of
those penalties my question is am i
right and I parade in support of myself
every conservative leader since Winston
Churchill all of whom believed that
Britain's self-interest Britain's
self-interest was inextricably
interwoven with Europe I believe it
today and I know
large numbers of MPs do believe it too
where is the The Voice who will change
the song you've been working for the
party since the 1950s how much
difficulty how much trouble is the
Conservative Party in right now I think
it is in serious risk of not winning the
next election if it goes on as it is now
that I am appalled I I find it almost
incredible having been in the House of
Commons with Jeremy Corbyn for all those
years so you've known something of his
views and something of the Labour's
views I find it almost incredible to
hear myself saying it but analysing the
way things are going looking at the
pinyon polls anticipating the
anticipated events as I think they'll
unfold it is now a very serious risk
what has sometimes many things being
realistic thank you